هذه هي بلده كويسنجر شرق اربيل التي تعرضت
لهاجمات ضمن سلسله هجمات الايرانيه على
ثلاث مواقع في اقليم كردستان العراق
حاولنا الاقتراب اكثر من المعسكر والدخول
الى اماكن القصف الا ان الامن الكردي حاله
دون ان ندخل الى هذه الاماكن بسبب معاوده
القصف الايراني على هذه الاماكن في اي
لحظه
قتيلاني وثمانيه جرح الحصيله النهائيه
للقصر الايراني على ثلاث مواقع في اقليم
كردستان العراق صبح حدود الساعه 8:30 بين
8:30
وصوت كل شيء مرعب وكل من اخذ اهله وربعه
وودعمم الكويت هاي كل مره تتكرر كل فتره
فتره
وبالتزاموني مع الهجوم بالمسيرات المفخخه
على بلدتك ماسنجر هجم الحرس الثوري
الايراني مواقع المعارضه الايرانيه شرقيه
محافظه السليمانيه وكذلك في بلده السيدا
كان شمال الشرقيه اربيل فيما تولت ردات
الفعل الغاضبه المستنكره لهاجمات ايران
اعتقد بانه نحن بحاجه الى مؤتمر
يجمع هذه الاطراف جميعها للوصول الى خارج
الطريق لانهاء هذه الاشكاليه والا هي
عمليات عمليات القصف المستمر عند السنوات
على الاقليم بحجه وجود معارضه
استمرارها بالتاكيد سيكون كارثه
الايراني اعلن عن استمراره في استهداف
الاراضي العراقيه تحت زريعه انهاء دعم
المعارضه الايرانيه للاحتجاجات
عمومي مدنيران من بلده الكويسنجر شرقيه
اربيل احمد الحمداني العربيه